hello we're here to talk about The
Secret World of Arrietty the latest from
Studio Ghibli and this is not a Miyazaki
directed film but it was written by him
based off the book the borrower's and a
very odd credit it just says planned by
him I don't know what that means I mean
doesn't sort of mean II kind of directed
her or maybe I don't know but it's not
directed by him but it's Studio Ghibli
from his studio um so okay
these damn films you know I think these
movies are gonna be look back on like
people are gonna look sorta look back on
these as like sort of classic films in a
sense because they're actually I think
these and Pixar films are really taking
their audience their younger audience
seriously and I freaking love that I
love the fact it's like hey we're not
gonna throw in pop cultural references
when I ain't gonna throw in like you
know two-year-old Joe's or poo poo jokes
or anything like that like and we're not
gonna you know do whatever his hip and
new it's like I like it when they're
just doing their own thing and they're
treating kids like they're smart like
they're gonna listen and I know they're
not always I I mean every way it's like
a lot of people come up to me don't you
think like you know sort of this naive
thought that kids will you know really
watch this stuffing there's a lot of
quiet moments there's a lot of dialogue
and stuff like that they at least
deserve the option okay I mean a lot of
films I grew up with i watch crap two
kids watch crab but we've you know kids
deserve the option to watch good stuff
smart stuff and I think the studio's
like Pixar in Studio Ghibli
are doing that and I I really admire
them for that this film from beginning
to end I just enjoyed watching all of it
I really I love these characters every
single one of them the set up like most
of you know or maybe you don't have
based off the borrower's which is little
people that live in
house and they quote unquote borrow
stuff it's stealing I never see them
give me the stuff back I mainly do in
the book I don't know I never read the
book but so and one of them named Derry
and he comes across this boy and before
the regular-sized boy and they form a
friendship and it's it's pretty much
just about that and again I like films
like this you don't need you know saw
these really manipulative contrived
story plots that people like to use over
and over even though this has been seen
before with you know there's a secret
world or secret people and they can't
let the humans know it's I'd be lying I
said I wasn't a little tired of that but
at the same time kids like that they
like that secret world this is just for
them so I cannot stand that and I get
why they keep using this plot over and
over though I was asking myself what why
hasn't someone done a story where like
whatever there's a secret person or a
secret alien or animal whatever and they
just tell everybody and like the alien
or whatever gets famous and people are
you know is shocked by am their alien
oven and stuff like that like that third
play of the Apes movie which was really
weird but it's like it was pretty cool
they didn't have to keep much of secret
it's like you know they just became
famous and maybe we can see what Fame
does to them or what what they can learn
or don't discover it it seems like you
can discover a lot more that way and you
can make more interesting commentary
more interesting adventures but I'm
really getting sidetracked it here okay
um it's it's are hard to talk about this
movie in terms of detail because well in
a sense it's all detail it's all about
this world that they inhabit of course
it's all that great Miyazaki stuff that
you love it's just how do these little
people live how do they get around what
are the tools that they use in music he
really seems to love tools they love to
show how things are done and I we love
watching them or at least I love
watching and I i think the most clever
thing was that they need to climb a wall
and so they have double sided tape that
they put on their hands on their feet
and they use that to climb up it's like
oh smart that's so clever I love that
stuff um and the relationship between
the boy and the girl is very good Liza
the the suicide character he of
housekeeper played by Carol Burnett
she's a lot of fun um here's my problem
with the film and this is a guy really
liked this film but there is a problem I
don't think it's major but it this film
could have been incredible this could
have been like an incredible movie
because they're dealing with things here
in an adult manner you know that are
pretty heavy like one of the characters
is possibly gonna die and we don't know
if the character is gonna die there's
also this issue about leaving your home
and finding a new home there's also
issues of you know communicating with
you know these other people whether or
not you should or shouldn't you know
being the last of your kind possibly as
well you know they only see one other
borrower from the outside world so
here's all this stuff that you can sort
of do I'm the only sort of tab on it the
the two things that come to my mind when
I think about this one is the element of
danger that they always indicate there's
serve danger everywhere the bill does
really good to do that like when they're
sneaking around they just make a kitchen
look really threatening and really big
and you know the answer are these creepy
sounds that really just sounds with
people moving around but they magnify
the minutes you really sort of get this
sense a you know you tense up a bit over
they are they gonna get caught so I'm
gonna happens the cat gonna see him it's
an end and it's great it really works
that danger never quite comes though
there's one scene pretty long scene so
near the end which I supposes the climax
where one of them gets caught and they
have to go in and kind of save her but
it's not that much danger it's sort you
feel more like this would be the middle
of the movie not the exciting climax or
either here's the thing I don't need
like a big action scene I really don't I
mean I was actually glad they didn't
have a big action scene but the cat
building up that there is gonna be
something like that like the Arrietty
girl finds a she finds a pin and she
holds it like a sword she takes it out
like a source you really loves taking
this thing out you know and acting like
she's gonna use it
at least never to fight off anything um
and again that they're really building
up that everything is served out to get
them in what a big cruel dangerous world
this is and they do sort of go out into
I guess before us is where they are and
you do see these other animals and they
look big and they look threatening but
they never attack I've never had to
fight anything off and they build up
that there's other powers out there that
maybe they could see and you see one of
them who sort of like this Tarzan type
boy you know and so you oh what else is
out there eh you know and the dangers
out there is that you never see it and
even okay and here's my other big issue
at the end with they they're sort of
tied together the ending I won't give it
away but there are we think second of
Miyazaki's films that he's directed us
to do Ghibli films in general I have
seen the other family of whispers of a
heart kept returns and stuff like that
they really have this thing where they
want to end it really fast and I don't
get that it's like you have this really
nice sweet moment the fields just
starting to end you know and they expect
to see like you know an epilogue or some
sort of understanding there or maybe
quite amaz and they start showing the
credits like half the time the film's
not even over like it's still going an
important part of the movie is going to
reveal itself while the credits and the
pop song are playing and that's really
distracting for example let's say in a
Lion King like let's say you know where
the good guy wins and he's just about to
go he's gonna roar at the you know Pride
Rock and stuff like that you know the
rains coming down what if while the
rains coming down the credits start it
it's just no the movies not done yet why
are you showing us the credits when the
film isn't over why are you showing us
the names of these people that worked
very hard on this movie when you're
distracting us with the rest of the film
there's no need for that and maybe it's
a cultural thing I don't know but this
film this film would have been a lot
stronger if I mean a if there was more
of a danger in it and they really sort
of address the dangers of all the stuff
they're talking about you know losing a
life or
going out into the unknown or finding a
new home if they really really they talk
about it but they don't fully address it
they don't go through it or at least we
don't see them go through it and now the
ways that would be really dramatic and
really huge um and I think and like I
said if this film just waited to show
its credits until the screen goes black
it would have been stronger I know it
sounds strange it's just when you show
the credits can really affect a film but
I mean for those who have seen this
movie really think about it think about
it they didn't show the credits when
they did and there's this long long
moment while the crowds are playing it
just imagine those credits weren't there
and just imagine that scene play out
what not then a much nicer scene would
have been a much stronger ending I
really feel it would of and I feel that
did serve distract from it so but that's
to me that's not a huge thing I mean
it's I think it kept it from being
something like that it likes to be
element danger kept it from being a
gigantic film this could have been a
really huge egg antic film but for what
it is it's still good I mean it is for
lack of a better word a small film
I mean it's meant to be as a small movie
and I get that when they're tackling
these issues though you it could have
been something phenomenal by effects of
that before um let's talk about real
quick just who would like it who would
not like it anyone that likes the Studio
Ghibli films the Miyazaki films or some
stuff like that will like it fine you
know it's still very creative they're
very likable characters well kids like
it you know like the your kid or
whatever possibly uh if your kid likes
the kid really likes this kind of
creativity and they they have this
patience for this kind of film which I
like I like it when kids they have this
way I had this pages growing up I think
a lot of kids do it's sort of hard to
sit him down and get through and they
might say once and this is boring but I
think they want to get through it they
want to see what happens
and even if afterward they're not like
that was the Greenes movie yeah it
sticks with them I like movies that do
that uh where kids don't realize this is
actually a really really good film you
know they might pharisee
transformers or something like that
that's a great film to them at that age
but as they get older it's like they
sort of think back to that one movie a
Transformers fades but that one movie
you know the did sir leave an impact and
as they get older they suddenly realize
that was hittin some of their I never
realized and I like movies that can do
that and that's what movies that you
know studio Jubilee and Pixar doing and
I really admire that and they're and
they're taking risks doing that you know
not doing the typical Sherlock you know
taking kids seriously so um so so I
think I think those kind of people would
like it who would not like it people
that you know maybe they want more meat
to you know the story because it is a
lie say it is a small story and it
doesn't it tackles you know issues like
death and moving and stuff but I mean
not not to a degree that a really strong
powerhouse movie could so if you're
looking for just sort of this nice small
movie you know this or this nice small
story you'll like it and you'll enjoy it
and the animation of course is wonderful
the voice acting is wonderful
we're played the boy in this I don't
know what play is Brice um celebrity or
something but really good job especially
when you find out what the kids going
through its er like wow this it's kid to
good like a really good but I mean
everybody did a good job and I can't
think of anyone that did bad every
character is memorable
um so outside that if you don't like
Miyazaki films or us dude cheaply
feelings you probably won't like this
and one or two people might be throwing
off a little bit by the ending and just
how quickly it sort of stops I mean no
it doesn't I mean there's an ending but
I mean it's like I said they're just so
fast to throw those credits at you and
they it got to me I think it gets to
other people too because the ending is
the most important part that's the last
thing you remember you know that's the
last thing you see you know make make an
impact don't rush it so I do really
really enjoy this film um
if and I probably like it more than
something like a pony or something like
that because I feel they they think it
connections there and you do serve feel
you feel a little bit of the way to what
they're talking about and I do love the
creativity of it as well and it likes it
it's just a nice little tail and I think
it does work and it's a very nice movie
so yeah that's about it I shall talk to
you guys later